hello guys and welcome back to the
channel as you can see I've got yet
another change of scenery in my
background here that's because I finally
moved into a place in Chicago which is
pretty sweet so no complaints there the
one thing is I am living alone for the
first time which means that I have a lot
more responsibility I'm also a lot more
likely to go completely insane and if I
do that would make these YouTube videos
a little bit more interesting so uh you
know in the best interest of all of us
let's see if that happens hopefully it
does but without further Ado let's start
talking about some replication I put you
guys in about a three week wild goose
chase to talk about crdts so let's get
back into it
all right so today we're going to get
started by talking about leaderless
replication so the gist of leaderless
replication is pretty simple and you can
see it right down here but basically now
instead of just writing to one node
which we've always done in the past
we're actually going to write to a bunch
of different nodes so that's chaos we're
going to be doing it even at the same
time and to make matters even worse
we're also going to be reading from a
ton of notes so everything that we know
so far throw it right out the window
because things are about to get real
so let's move on where do we actually
use leaderless replication again I'm
going to try and make an emphasis on
actually pointing out some systems that
do these things so you know you can
contextualize these videos a little bit
uh this is definitely used in Cassandra
that's probably the most popular One
open source database ryak is another
open source database very similar to
Cassandra and then you may happen to
think that this is used in dynamodb
which many people seem to say online
however they would be incorrect because
actually this type of leaderless
replication was originally invented in
the open source Amazon Dynamo paper but
dynamodb as far as I can tell seems to
use single leader replication it's kind
of unclear I would not say that dynamodb
uses leaderless for application if it
were to come up in an interview
okay so let's move on how does this
thing actually work so here's a very
realistic scenario we've got Kate Upton
as per usual on the left over here and
she is going to write that Jordan is
cute to a few different databases so
let's say that she writes it to two of
them so as you can see we have three
different databases each of them with
basically some sort of snapshot
versioning we've spoken about this in
the past but let's imagine that the
Jordan key has a version so originally
it starts out as version 20 on all three
of these databases and then the two that
get the right which are this guy and
this guy are now updating version 21 to
Jordan equal to Q then of course Jordan
is going to read those values from these
two databases and he's going to see the
following version 21 of Jordan equals Q
version 20 of Jordan equals ugly so
technically we have two conflicting
values here of the Jordan key but keep
in mind that that's what these versions
are for right because we know that 21 is
greater than 20.
we know that the actual most up-to-date
value is that Jordan is equal to Q
and another actually cool thing that you
can do in this leaderless replication is
me being Jordan can see that you know
this guy this database over here
database number three has an outdated
value for Jordan and so he's actually
going to write back saying hey for
version number 21 we know that Jordan is
actually equal to Q so then this guy
over here is going to basically update
its value and say oh you know what I
just got a new update it turns out
Jordan is actually cute
and the process of actually taking a
database with a stale value and updating
it after performing a read is known as
read repair so this is important to know
and the reason that's useful is because
it is one of the basically two main ways
that we can make sure that our data
values are up to date so let's take a
look at the other way of ensuring that
our values are up to date so this one is
called anti-entropy
so the gist here is we've got these two
leader databases or just in general
databases because there isn't really a
leader in this setup and the list of
letters below are the rights that
they've processed so this guy on the
left is processed a c e f g and on the
right he's processed b c d f and g so
let's imagine then that basically the
left database wants to replicate all of
those changes to the database on the
right so that they have at least similar
data right so typically in a single
leader or a multi-leader setup we would
use the replication log right and that's
just going to be one long list of all
the rights that have happened on that
node and you're passing each right one
at a time over the network from one
database to the other however in this
case it doesn't really make sense to do
that the reasoning being that this
database over here on the right is
probably already going to have a lot of
the information that is contained on the
left because of the fact that rights go
to multiple places so we don't actually
want to send every write that might be
in a replication log but we actually
only want to send select rights that are
present on the Node on the left but not
present on the Node on the right so
that's the whole point over here we only
want to send rights A and E
so how can we actually quickly tell
which rights to send well the easiest
way would be to literally scan through
all of the values and rights present on
the left node that are not present in
the right node however there are a
couple of issues with that the first one
being that these are large tables and
when you have large tables in order to
perform a scan over them that is linear
time complexity it takes a while to
perform and additionally it might have
to be a ton of data that we're sending
over the network to basically have those
two databases confirm with one another
that you know one has certain rows and
the other doesn't so what can we do
instead that's better well it's time to
introduce a concept known as the Markle
tree so I've spoken about this in the
past on my channel but for the new
series obviously we're going to
reintroduce it so here's how a Merkle
tree would work so let's imagine we have
a database that looks like this right
here so we've got four rows and
basically it's a key value pair of a
equals 10 B is 45 C is 63 and D is seven
so I'll explain how these Miracle trees
work in a little bit but the general
gist is that you want to use them to
tell how to database tables differ
really quickly and efficiently so let's
create the Merkle tree for our database
table right here so the first thing that
we're going to do this is Step One is we
take the hash of each row so let's
imagine that our hash function generates
output from zero to a thousand and these
numbers right here the four outputs that
we get from hashing
then from there we're going to take all
pairs of hashes we're going to sum them
up and then we're also going to take
hashes of those so in this case 762 plus
127 is 889 hence why we're taking the
hash of 889 and we do the sum again and
we take the hash of 1339. so now finally
we have 574 and 626 and then we're going
to do that same step one more time until
we get to one root node right so we take
these two we sum them up conveniently
they sum up to 1200 we take the hash of
them and let's imagine that spits out
213 which leads us to our final result
over here on the right so 213 is going
to be our root note of the Merkle tree
with two children as 574 626 and then of
course we're going to have our Leaf
nodes which are 762 127 901 and 438
so let's scroll down a little bit more
because we've seen how to create a
Merkel tree but how can they actually be
useful for us so let's imagine now that
we have two database tables right we've
got uh all four rows again we've got a b
c and d and the only difference between
the two of them is that as you can see
here B is equal to six and on the right
B is equal to nine so what can we use
these Miracle trees to do well let's say
we took a look at these two trees and we
said all right where are these databases
different just using the Merkle trees so
we'll start by looking at the root nodes
between them we've got 305 and 642.
those two are not equal so clearly
there's got to be a difference somewhere
in this Merkle tree right the next thing
we would do is start with the children
let's do a breadth first search for now
so we'll take a look at 119 and we'll
say 119 is different than 505 so we know
eventually we'll have to keep going down
this path similarly or actually in this
case differently
463 is equal to 463 on the right so we
actually don't have to care about any of
these entries over here because we know
that everything under 463 is highly
likely to be the same we don't have to
take a look at those or worry about it
all we have to do is inspect the left
half of this tree right now
so now moving on down our tree we can
see that 746 is equal to 746 so we've
got no issues there like I said a is 10
in both trees but then finally because
821 is different than 314 we found our
difference between the two trees it's
just the fact that b is equal to 9 first
B is equal to 6 and now if these were
two databases for example we could send
the facts that b is equal to 6 to this
guy over the network we're only sending
one row instead of the whole table so
it's much more efficient and then it can
change its value and say oh shoot B is
equal to 6. the really nice thing about
this again is instead of having to do a
linear scan over the whole table and
figure out where they're different this
is an O of log n why because we're
creating a binary tree and binary trees
are basically continuing to split the
table into two over and over and over
again and that gives us logarithmic time
complexity so for now basically that is
going to be the introductory video for
leaderless replication but next next
time around we are going to get into a
very very important concept which we
didn't touch upon too much just yet and
so the point there is that so far we've
seen how rights will go from one
database to another in the cluster but
what we haven't seen is how we can
actually guarantee that if I'm a guy on
the left here and I'm writing to a few
nodes how do I know that my guy on the
right is going to see that right away
because right now the guy on the right
has to wait for something like
anti-entropy he could in theory do some
read repair but if he were doing read
repair that would be reliant on the fact
that one of these two nodes that he's
reading from is going to be one of the
three that gets written to so read
repair isn't actually going to work for
us here you have to wait for some
unclear amount of time for anti-entropy
to happen and sometimes that's not good
enough so in theory there is a way that
we can actually guarantee that this guy
on the right is going to make sure that
he sees all of the rights made by the
guy on the left and that is going to be
the topic for next video anyways guys
have a good one I'll see you in the next
one and I'm looking forward to it